niños cargados a hombros y lo que queda
de las pertenencias en unas cuantas
bolsas plásticas así avanza la
evacuación de miles de civiles en la
región de gersón tras la destrucción de
La Represa de kahoovka
equipados con pequeñas lanchas
neumáticas estos soldados ucranianos
ayudan con las labores en uno de los
distritos inundados según las
autoridades ucranianas el nivel del agua
ha subido 3,5 metros en algunas partes
de gersón y más de 40.000 personas están
en zona de riesgo y cientos de miles han
quedado sin acceso a agua potable
nos inundamos hasta aquí No sé todo está
sumergido en el agua todos los muebles
la nevera la comida todas las flores
todo está flotando no sé qué hacer unas
decenas de kilómetros más arriba del Río
niefer en zonas controladas por las
autoridades rusas las evacuaciones
también han comenzado
Moscú y kiev se culpan mutuamente del
ataque a la presa y la destrucción de la
central hidroeléctrica el presidente no
acusó a Rusia de detonar una bomba
medioambiental
mundo entero conocerá este crimen de
guerra ruso El crimen de ecocidio esta
destrucción deliberada por parte de los
ocupantes rusos de la presa y otras
estructuras de la central hidroeléctrica
de kahooca es una bomba medioambiental
de destrucción masiva y en una reunión
de la ONU el martes Rusia habló de
Sabotaje por parte de kiev El Sabotaje
deliberado llevado a cabo por kiev
contra una instalación de
infraestructura crítica es
extremadamente peligroso y puede
clasificarse esencialmente como crimen
de guerra o acto de terrorismo los
expertos por su parte describen una
catástrofe cuyas consecuencias se
sentirán durante décadas y que será de
Gran alcance para ambas partes en la
línea de frente